all right well let's ditch the
traditional chocolate or roses this
valentine's day and get your significant
other something they will really love
jillian joins us from max pond to show
us some chicken nuggets no she's gonna
take us shopping for diamonds and
watches
all right i'm having too much fun here
inside max pond we are talking all
things jewelry diamonds watches even i'm
in love with this rolex that i have on
here michael you're spoiling me i'm
never going to want to leave well i'm
spoiled you're actually your husband's
going to have to spoil you yes i hope
he's watching let's talk about some of
these beautiful watches i can't look
away from this one so this is a cartier
tank watch
it's gorgeous 18 karat gold with the
diamonds going all the way around this
is a factory watch
all my watches come with five year
warranties guaranteed authentic this is
a datejust to
just a datejust with the jubilee band
as you can tell with that watch this
watch and this watch men and women can
wear their unisex this is a daytona 18
carat rose gold very rare
70 thousand dollar watch in the
marketplace we're selling it for 55 000.
oh my gosh i'm nervous wearing this
right now but it's an incredible deal
and you guys are having a big sale for
valentine's day and just in general
valentine's and galentines for those
we have great savings up to 70 off
retail uh we got some fun and bubblies
and strawberries through the holiday and
we we welcome anyone locals are
obviously welcome tourists as well so uh
come down and shop max spawn yeah you
make it a really fun experience and even
just to come look and the way the light
hits everything it truly is like the
disneyland of diamonds in here and let's
talk a little bit about your
authentication and just you know you're
getting the real deal when you come into
max pond well really the biggest thing
that we sell is authentication and great
customer service so everything in the
store is authentic all handbags are
third-party authenticated comes like
with a little chanel card
shares that it's authentic tells why
it's authentic
watches come with a watch csa it's
another third party certificate diamonds
typically come with a gia certificate so
authentic is our is like what we breed
because you don't typically think of a
pawn shop with all these good things but
this is max pond luxury and we're
looking open more stores and have more
fun yeah people keep coming through the
door here left and right they are super
busy in here so if you want to come
check out max pond let's tell people
where we are right now how they can find
you and anything else they might need to
know we're on the northeast corner of
saharan jones we've been here for 13
years uh you can shop us at
shopmaxbond.com well thank you so much i
have a new love for this rolex watch and
these diamonds i'm staying here all day
i'll send it back to you guys